this is the situation what we haven't
had in our national leadership is
leaders who say we recognize this as a
problem we're going to address this
problem we're going to find common
ground between the parties and stop the
trend downward that is downward trend
being an ever widening gap between those
who have and those who have not it's
been a you know it's been a constant in
our country since the very beginning but
has gotten worse with each succeeding
decade in the 20th century if we don't
stand united
yet United and move forward on this
question we our children and
grandchildren are going to have a quite
a different country dan Rather is the
co-author of what unites us reflections
on patriotism mr. Wrather thank you
thank you very much I appreciate you we
now go to the House of Representatives
let us pray merciful God we give you
thanks for giving us another day bless
the members of this assembly as they
return to their districts to listen to
and communicate with their constituents
about the issues and affairs currently
being considered in Congress it is the
weekend our nation remembers its
veterans upon whom we ask your blessing
may our nation be faithful to those
still with us providing whatever their
needs may be after they gave years of
their lives and service to our country
rather than dedicated to personal gain
they are an inspiration to us and we
should not forget nor neglect our
responsibilities to them as the nation
pauses to show its respect may we be
forever grateful for the blessings you
have bestowed upon the United States of
America may our nation continue to be a
beacon of hope for the world and may all
we do be for your greater honor and
glory amen the cheers examined the
Journal of the last day's proceedings
and announces to the house his approval
thereof pursuant to Clause 1 of rule 1
the journal stands approved
the pledge of allegiance will be led by
the gentleman from Arkansas mr.
westerman the chair will entertain up to
five requests for one-minute speeches on
each side of the aisle for what purpose
does the gentleman from Arkansas seek
recognition without objection the
gentleman is recognized
Mr Speaker I rise today to pay tribute
to the 15 men and women recently
inducted into the Arkansas military
veterans Hall of Fame of the 15
inductees the Hall of Fame selected 10
exclusively for their brave military
service to our country
Hall it's selected an additional five
for their combined military and civilian
service to our community state and
nation I am proud to note that eight of
these 15 American heroes held from the
fourth congressional district of
Arkansas serving in conflicts ranging
from world war ii to vietnam as well as
iraq and afghanistan this speech simply
is not enough time to recognize their
courage and sacrifice for our nation Mr
Speaker I ask unanimous consent to
submit to the record a brief biography
of each of the fourth District heroes
honored by the Arkansas military
veterans Hall of Fame and I extend my
thanks to all those who served as we
recognize Veterans Day I yield back
still anneals back for what purpose does
the gentleman from Maryland seek
recognition
one minute and if necessary to revise
and extend
for that objection Mr Speaker I rise
today in support of every immigrant who
has been granted temporary protective
status in my district and across the
nation we have nearly 23,000 in Maryland
the six highest in the country and 4,000
in my district one of the top five
districts in the country many people
with TPS fled countries such as Haiti El
Salvador Somalia and Syria ravaged by
armed conflicts or environmental
disasters for over 20 years they have
raised their families here in the United
States they're our neighbors and our
co-workers their kids attend our schools
TPS holders have been woven into the
fabric of our communities earlier this
week
those from Nicaragua were told they'll
be deported those from Honduras Honduras
is our next deporting people and giving
them mere months to pack their bags
after 20 years in the United States is
cruel and isn't who we are as Americans
mr. speaker as the Trump administration
puts the lives of thousands in legal
limbo I urge my colleagues to ensure TP
hold at EPS holders can stay and pursue
an earned path to citizenship I yield
back my time mr. speaker gentleman
yields back his time for what purpose
does the gentleman from California seek
recognition
without objection the gentleman is
recognized for one minute
Thank You mr. speaker as a house
constant contemplates the tax cuts and
Jobs Act a lot of misinformation is
getting around the country on that the
intent here is to make simpler the tax
code the ability for Americans have
spend instead of billions of hours and
billions of dollars combined on dealing
with their taxes to get it down to a
simple form perhaps a postcard for many
Americans and the ability to weed
through their taxes and get them done
and put more money in their pockets what
our plan does is put approximately 1,200
dollars into the average middle income
families pocket leaves it there instead
of taking it out also restoring more
opportunity on Main Street for small
misses mean medium businesses and the
things that the jobs we want to come
back home to this country those truly
of dollars we can paint repatriate back
to this country and help the middle
class help middle-income Americans help
everybody to have a stronger more
vibrant economy which helps everybody
instead of a complicated tax code put
together by lobbyists we need to push
forward on this and have a success for
the American people
Mr Speaker I yield back Joey yields back
for what purpose does the gentleman from
North Carolina seek recognition without
objection the gentleman is recognized
for one minute
Thank You mr. Speaker I rise today in
opposition to the tax cuts and Jobs Act
also known as the Trick Trick Trick Act
this bill mr. speaker includes a 1 and a
half trillion dollar cut to Medicare and
Medicaid raises taxes on middle-income
families gives the biggest tax cuts to
corporations and the wealthiest
Americans this bill eliminates personal
deductions for medical expenses creating
further hardship for people facing
illnesses eliminates deductions for
state and local income taxes resulting
in higher taxes for people who can't
afford it and eliminates deductions for
interest paid on student loans making
quality education less accessible
proponents of the bill mr. speaker will
have you to believe that these tax cuts
benefit working families grow up grow
our economy and decrease the federal
deficit that's fake news this bill does
nothing more than destroy the hopes and
dreams of middle Americans seeking a
stable career a fulfilled life and a
brighter future the American people
deserve better
I remain willing and able to work across
the party lines to achieve responsible
tax reform I say to my Republican
colleagues do not pass this bill as a
Republican bill it must be bipartisan if
you do it you will regret it are you
back gentleman yields back for what
purpose does the gentlelady from
Missouri seek recognition
the house for one minute without
objection the gentlelady is recognized
for one minute
Thank You mr. Speaker I rise today to
honor and thank mr. Stephen Gaither for
his dedication and service to our
nation's veterans after over 40 years of
service mr. Gaither is retiring as the
public affairs officer at the harry s
truman memorial Veterans Hospital in
Columbia Missouri mr. Gaither has spent
his entire life serving this great
nation
in addition to his numerous years
serving our veterans at the Truman VA
mr. Gaither served in the United States
Air Force the Utah
Air National Guard and the Army Reserves
since 1989 he has been an active
volunteer for the heart of Missouri
United Way a nonprofit organization that
works to improve the economic and social
conditions of those that reside in our
local community his passion for serving
others will forever leave a mark on the
Truman VA and the city of Columbia so
mr. Gaither this week as we celebrate
Veterans Day I want to thank you for
your devotion and your work on behalf of
our nation's veterans and our community
and I want to wish you the very best in
your retirement Mr Speaker I yield back
gentlelady yields back her time for what
purpose does the gentlelady from virgin
islands seek recognition
without objection the gentlelady is
recognized for one minute
thank you Mr Speaker I ask unanimous
consent to on behalf of my family and
staff I want to salute and commemorate
the veterans of the US Virgin Islands
and throughout the United States on this
Veterans Day the Virgin Islands along
with other territories send more men and
women per capita to serve in the US
military than anywhere else in this
nation I would like to personally
recognize Task Force Alfonse and Kroy
task force Bravo on st. Thomas and st.
John responders on Veterans Day we
salute the men and women who have
proudly worn the uniform and the
families who have served alongside them
and we affirm our sacred duty as
citizens to express our enduring
gratitude both in words and actions for
their service as part of Veterans Day
this year in the Virgin Islands will
be honoring female veterans in the
territory being honored as parade
marshal and guest speaker on the island
of st. Croix is major kathleen paris on
st. thomas sergeant first class laurel
malumed francis serving as parade
marshal and serving as guest speaker on
the island of Saint Thomas will be
former military spouse Monique Y Ferrell
Director of Army sexual harassment
assault response and Prevention SPAC
program mr. speaker just as we vowed to
leave no soldier behind on the
battlefield we vowed not to forget any
veteran when they returned home I yield
back
gentlelady yields back for what purpose
does the gentleman from Texas seek
recognition without objection the
gentleman ask for one minute Mr Speaker
I have a message for the liberal
so-called mainstream media you are
essential to democracy you have an
almost sacred responsibility to inform
the American people but they don't
believe you anymore your coverage of the
President and conservative Republicans
is now obviously so slanted so biased
that you have lost your credibility in
fact polls show that it is at a record
low in trying to destroy this president
you are destroying yourself is that what
you want
remember the Chinese proverb when you
set out on a journey of revenge dig two
graves why not trust the American people
with the facts and let them make up
their own minds rather than telling them
what to think I don't know of any other
way you can restore your credibility
gentleman yields back his time for what
per the JD from seek recognition
without objection gentlelady is
recognized for one minute
Thank You mr. speaker each November
communities across the country observed
National Diabetes Awareness Month we
come together to educate our neighbors
and to bring attention to the impact
that diabetes has in the lives of
millions of Americans as a diabetic I
know the challenges faced by people with
this condition in 2015 diabetes was the
seventh leading cause of death for
Americans and diagnosis rates continue
to grow each year to live a long and
prosperous life with this disease it's
imperative that diabetes receive proper
nutrition and access to health care
thanks to the Affordable Care Act
pre-existing conditions such as diabetes
are covered by health insurance and
thanks to snap the poorest in our
communities have access to nutrition but
ACA and snap are under attack and as a
member of the diabetes caucus and as
your representative in Congress I'll
continue to vigorously protect the ACA
and fight to increase snap benefits for
those in need my life is a living
testament to the opportunities that
exist when diabetes is properly treated
we must ensure these opportunities are
available for the next generation I
yield back
gentlelady yields back her time for what
purpose does the gentleman from Florida
seek recognition without objection the
gentleman is recognized for one minute
Mr Speaker I appreciate it November is
Diabetes Awareness Month over 30 million
children and adults including myself
suffer from diabetes another 34 84
million have pre-diabetes and 90% of
them don't even know it diabetes can
cause stroke blindness kidney disease
heart disease loss of toes feet or even
legs in addition to the personal toll
this disease takes on the lives of those
affected health care costs for diabetic
patients are three two point three times
greater than those without diabetes this
awful disease costs the health care
system and that's made three hundred
twenty two billion dollars rate of
diabetes
have risen rates have risen dramatically
unfortunately in recent years we must do
something to stop it the US Congress is
working towards that in I was proud to
have worked on the 21st century cures
Act which invests in research for a cure
the bill streamlines the FDA approval
process and provides more money for
research to the NIH there is much more
we can do mr. speaker to tackle this
serious public health issue thank you
and I yield back
time of the gentleman has expired for
what purpose does the gentleman from
Texas mr. Hensarling seek recognition
the speaker pursuant to House Resolution
609 I call up HR 2201 the micro offering
safe harbor Act and ask for its
immediate consideration in the house the
clerk will report the title of the bill
Thank You Union calendar number 280 HR
2201 a bill to amend the Securities Act
of 1933 to exempt certain micro
offerings from the registration
requirements as such Act and further
purposes pursuant to House Resolution
691 our debate on the bill it shall be
in order to consider the amendment
printed in House report 11.22.13 informe
Texas mr. Hensarling and the gentlewoman
from California mrs. waters each will
control 30 minutes
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
Texas
we speak I yield myself as much time as
I may consume
gentleman is recognized Thank You mr.
speaker we know that unfortunately after
eight years of bad economic policies
from the Obama administration working
people did not receive a pay increase we
know that we had one of the lowest late
participation rates in modern history we
know that the economy was limping along
at one and a half to two percent
economic growth but fortunately mr.
speaker a new day has dawned and now all
of a sudden we see that with the
policies of Republicans in Congress with
the policies of the Trump administration
we're seeing promising signs what we're
seeing all of sudden now is to two
quarters mr. speaker a 3% plus economic
growth
this means a difference to working
families they're finally seeing
increases in their paychecks increases
in their take-home pay and that is why
one of the most exciting policies that
are being worked upon today that we hope
to see soon is fundamental pro-growth
tax reform for the entire American
economy one that would grow our economy
that makes a tax code fairer flatter
simpler more competitive one that would
lower rates for families and allow
ninety percent of Americans to fill out
their forms on something akin to a
postcard something that would help our
small businesses and entrepreneurs and I
look forward mr. speaker to having that
legislation on the floor soon but we
have legislation today legislation today
that is also important to our small
businesses in our entrepreneurs HR 2201
by the gentleman from Minnesota and
what's so important about this
legislation mr. speaker is that it would
allow our entrepreneurs and our small
businesses to more effectively be able
to reach out to family and friends to
get the needed capital to start their
businesses a 2014 survey by the Kauffman
Foundation found out that over 28
percent of startups raise their funding
from their personal network but Mr
Speaker we have a challenge and that is
the Securities Act does not clearly
define what is a public offering or
conversely a non-public offering so this
makes it very difficult for our
early-stage entrepreneurs
toriel growth companies to go out and do
any kind of private placement to raise
funds from friends and family now we
know that a private placement is already
something that is established in law but
what isn't established is a bright-line
safe harbor for these business
enterprises to go out and raise these
funds and so what we also know
unfortunately from our Securities and
Exchange Commission a registered
offering is simply not economically
feasible for a small business and
entrepreneur and issuer who is seeking
to raise less than a million dollars and
so too often mr. speaker we have a
number of these enterprises that frankly
just never get jump-started because they
don't have the opportunity for a private
offering and that's why it's so
important I want to thank the gentleman
from Minnesota mr. Emmer for his
leadership in bringing this legislation
to the House floor today and so it's a
simple piece of legislation again it
simply allows a bright-line safe harbor
for very very small offerings it
requires that each purchaser has a
substantive pre-existing relationship
with an officer director or shareholder
of the issuer the issuer must reasonably
believe that there are no more than 35
35 purchaser of the securities in the
aggregate amount of all securities sold
by the issuer cannot exceed a half a
million in a 12-month period so mr.
speaker we're talking about a very very
small portion of startups but a very
vitally important section of our
startups that need capital you know mr.
speaker a couple a few decades ago there
was a company where gentlemen borrowed
money from his father to import Japanese
sports shoes and he purchased 200 pairs
of these Japanese sports shoes he
started a business called Blue Ribbon
sports and today we know it as Nike a
few decades ago there was an investor
not know maja Nebraska who borrowed
money from seven
friends and family members including his
sister Doris and Aunt Alice and over the
night over the next nine years this
initial investment grew and this
gentleman purchased something called
Berkshire Hathaway a textile company
that has now led to the Berkshire
Hathaway Empire in 1994 there was a
gentleman who took a loan from his
parents moved to a two-bedroom small
apartment launched a company called
Amazon we want to make sure that the
next Brookshire halfway the next Amazon
get launched and that's why it's so
critical we enact HR 2200 1 and I
reserve the balance of my time the
gentleman reserves the balance of his
time
the gentlelady from California heyyo
myself such time as I may consume
gentlelady is recognized mr. speaker HR
2201 would create an unnecessary and
potentially dangerous loophole in
federal and state securities laws by
allowing companies to sell unregistered
securities without important safeguards
that normally apply to such transactions
specifically the bill would allow a
company to raise up to $500,000 from 35
or pure investors subject only to the
requirement that each of these investors
have a substantive pre-existing
relationship with the company currently
before a company can offer or sell its
securities it must either register the
offering with the Securities and
Exchange Commission that is the SEC or
qualify for at least one of several
existing exemptions from registration
these exemptions provide reduced
regulatory requirements for businesses
conducting the offerings but are limited
to investors who have the financial
sophistication to understand the risk or
enough asset to bear losses without the
full protections of the securities
additionally unlike HR 2201 these
existing exemptions include several
critical critical investor protections
such as notice to regulators limitations
on advertising and restrictions on
resale for example securities offered
pursuant to rule 506 of Regulation D are
restricted meaning they cannot be resold
for at least a year without registering
them that is re registered them
additionally the registration exemptions
available under the crowdfunding rules
and regulation a impose limitations on
the amounts individual can invest in a
year there by placing a cap on potential
losses HR 2200 ones lack of basic
safeguards would leave investors
vulnerable to an array of investment
scams for example a purchase of
securities offered pursuant to HR 2201
would be able to immediately resell the
securities and secondary transactions in
the past the failure to restrict the
resale of unregistered securities has
exposed secondary investors to pump and
dump schemes a form of fraud that
involves hyping up cheap junk stock in
order to resell it at a higher price to
unwitting investors additionally
investor and consumer advocates like
Americans for financial reform Center
for American Progress and Public Citizen
oppose HR 2201 because it would enable a
particularly deceptive scam known as
affinity fraud bed act bad actors
perpetrating affinity fraud could use HR
2201 to prey upon religious communities
ethnic groups and the elderly just a few
years ago the SEC shut down a scheme
targeting the Hispanic community in
Southern California the perpetrators
raised more than $800,000 by
presenting to close friends and family
members that their investments would be
used to develop a financial services
firm serving the Hispanic community
the SEC found that instead of developing
the purported business the scammers
quote used a large part of the investors
money to engage unsuccessfully in
high-risk day trading of stocks pay
personal living travel and entertainment
expenses or make other unexplained
expenditures with no connection to
purport it start a business activities
quote unquote
HR 2201 would provide a roadmap for bad
actors to similarly rip off investors
the bills $500,000 cap on offerings does
not eliminate the need for robust
safeguards against fraud and abuse in
fact these protections are even more
important for offerings of this size
given the proliferation of investment
schemes in the smaller offering space
the SEC has found that quote fraud in
the micro-cap stock markets is of
increasing concern to regulators as such
markets have proven to be fertile
grounds for fraud and abuse quote
unquote while $500,000 may not seem like
a lot on Wall Street for Main Street
Americans losing even a fraction of that
amount would destroy the hope of one day
retiring with dignity existing
exemptions such as those available under
the SCC's Regulation D regulation aim
and crowdfunding rules provide ample
opportunities for companies to raise
capital while also protecting investors
HR 2201 would only expose hardworking
Americans to a new and wholly
unnecessary risk
but these reasons I urge my colleagues
to vote no on HR 2201 and I reserve the
balance of my time
the gentlelady reserves the balance of
her time
from Texas miss picker ask unanimous
consent that all members may have five
legislative days within which to revise
and extend their remarks and submit
extraneous materials on the bill under
consideration and mr. speaker
without objection yeah now pleased to
yield five minutes to the sponsor of the
legislation an outstanding member of the
Financial Services Committee the
gentleman from Minnesota mr. Emmer jenna
is recognized Thank You mr. chairman
while government isn't meant to create
jobs with the help of the president
Congress can set federal policies that
establish a pro-worker pro-business
environment that lifts people out of
poverty helps families and drives our
country forward one problem today that
is impeding job growth is access to
capital for small businesses American
business men and women are often unable
to get the loans they need to start a
new enterprise or to grow an existing
one additionally if a firm would like to
publicly sell stock to raise money it
must register with the Securities and
Exchange Commission which costs 2.5
million dollars on average an amount
most small businesses simply cannot
afford small and emerging businesses are
key to the economic engine in America
the Small Business Administration found
that these businesses create over half
of new of the new jobs on an annual
basis in this country more importantly
today's small businesses are tomorrow's
success story just think of all the
great businesses in this country that
started with a dream in a garage Amazon
Apple Microsoft Disney harley-davidson
and Minnesota's own Medtronic we want to
empower the entrepreneurs in this
country to dream innovate and create
jobs that grow our economy that's why I
introduced a micro offering safe harbor
app this bill will make it easy for
entrepreneurs and small businesses to
raise money from family friends and
their personal network without running
afoul of the vague and undefined private
offering safe harbor provision in the
Securities Act of 1933
thus the micro offering safe harbor act
helps bring clarity to existing law so
that our current and future job creators
can easily raise cap
within the confines of an
easy-to-understand provision without the
help of an expert this legislation
requires three specific criteria to be
met simultaneously in order to trigger a
safe harbor exemption for a security off
offering instead of just one or more
these criteria ensure that one each
purchaser has a substantive pre-existing
relationship with an owner to there are
no more than 35 purchasers of securities
from the issuer that are sold in
reliance on the exemption during the 12
months preceding and 3 the aggregate
amount of all securities sold by the
issuers does not exceed $500,000 during
the 12-month period preceding the
offering the bill also exempts any of
the aforementioned security offerings
from blue sky laws while maintaining
anti-fraud provisions at the federal and
state level
these provisions protect Americans from
criminals trying to swindle them out of
their hard-earned money while making
capital more accessible to businesses by
investors from around the country in
fact I will be offering an amendment to
enhance these anti-fraud provisions this
amendment which incorporates the
suggestions made by my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle during a
legislative hearing in the last Congress
will ensure that individuals who have
been disqualified under the bad actor
disqualification standard as is listed
under current law are prohibited from
using the exemption provided under HR
2201 establishing yet an additional
layer of investor protection
entrepreneurs and small business owners
need access to capital in order to
achieve the American dream although
small businesses accounted for
ninety-nine point seven percent of all
the businesses in the United States last
year only half of them will survive
longer than five years according to our
Bureau of Labor Statistics lack of
capital or difficulty accessing capital
is one of the main causes of failure for
many of these small businesses a 2015
survey conducted by blue vine found that
75% of small and emerging business
owners reported their primary source of
funding comes from their own personal
finances followed by banks at 16% and
family and friends at
six percent while banks and credit
unions do their best to offer the
funding these businesses need to grow
and thrive there are still three million
fewer small business loans made annually
today than there were before the 2008
financial crisis
HR 2201 seeks to build off the success
of the JumpStart our business startups
Act of 2012
better known as the JOBS Act and will
continue to spur capital formation for
the true job creators and drivers of our
country's economy the micro offering
safe harbor act helps small and emerging
companies add another tool to the
toolkit enabling them to confidently
find alternative ways of raising these
funds without having to pay for costly
securities experts and without the fear
of lawsuits if they operate within these
easy-to-understand parameters that is
why the micro safe offering safe harbor
act is endorsed by the National Small
Business Association the small business
and entrepreneurship Council the
National Federation of Independent
businesses the Chamber of Commerce
heritage action and engine the voice of
startups in government the House
approved an identical version of this
legislation during one hundred and
fourteenth Congress as part of the
accelerating access to capital Act and
language similar to HR 2201 was in Cloyd
included in the financial choice Act
which was adopted by this chamber in
June hearing the gentleman an additional
30 seconds German is recognized for an
additional 30 seconds the time has come
for Congress to come together and help
small businesses help themselves by
making this important update and
improvement to the Securities Act of
1933 I want to thank chairman Hensarling
capital markets subcommittee chairman
Huizenga and all of the staff on the
Financial Services Committee for their
hard work on this legislation and I urge
my colleagues to support this
legislation and hope that both parties
will use and use HR 2201 as a way to
show their support for more
opportunities and better lives for our
job creators I yield back
gentleman yields back gentleman from
Texas reserves his time
gentlelady from California Thank You mr.
Speaker I yield such time as he may
consume to the gentleman from Rhode
Island mr. Cicilline the gem is
recognized I thank the gentlelady for
yielding I want to begin mr. speaker by
responding to the gentleman from Texas
who began this too
by saying how this was a continuation of
an ongoing effort by Republicans to
promote pro-growth pro-growth tax reform
in particular I want to be very clear
mr. speaker the proposal that is
currently before this house with respect
to the tax a changes as a tax scam it's
not a tax plan it's a scam it gives one
and a half trillion dollars in tax cuts
to the wealthiest Americans the biggest
corporations the millionaires and
billionaires it increases taxes on tens
of millions of middle-class families and
it pays for this big gift back to
corporations and billionaires and
millionaires by deep cuts in Medicare
Medicaid infrastructure spending
education the things that actually
create jobs it creates additional
incentives to ship American jobs
overseas creates incentives for American
companies to take jobs here and ship
them overseas not to keep them here in
our own country
it's another may be more robust example
of trickle-down economics it has failed
before it will fail again we might have
the miracle people might have the
benefit of understanding this more
completely if there were actually a
process where this was debated witnesses
testified experts came in to talk about
the implications of this but this is
being done in the dark of night at the
speed of light so the American people
won't find out what's about to happen to
them so the idea of describing this as
pro-growth in this context both with the
provisions and the process seems to me
laughable let me just give the American
people a couple of examples it denies
individuals the right to deduct state
and local taxes but preserves that right
for corporations it denies a worker
who's forced to leave his home and move
because his employer is moving easily to
do that or he loses his job from denying
the cost of moving but it preserves the
right of it a company who's offshoring
jobs overseas to take a deduction for
the cost of moving those American jobs
overseas those are just two examples
so this isn't a pro-growth tax policy
this is trickle-down economics designed
to let the people at the very top hold
on to more their money corporations to
keep more of their profits in the hope
that will trickle down to the some to
the rest of the American people it
doesn't work it doesn't represent a
pro-growth tax policy it's a tax scam
and so I wanted to just correct the
record mr. speaker with all due respect
to the gentleman from Texas but I rise
in addition to that mr. speaker to
express my strong opposition to HR 22:01
the micro offerings safe harbor act in
light of the devastating 2008 financial
crisis and the regulatory weaknesses
revealed by the Wells Fargo and Equifax
scandals we should be considering
legislation that will bolster consumer
and investor protections but today
instead we're considering HR 2201 which
will enable abusive financial practices
generally a company that seeks to make
public offerings must register them with
the Securities and Exchange Commission
or must fit into one of several
exceptions that are designed to balance
investor protections with regulatory
burdens on smaller companies this
legislation would allow so-called micro
cap offerings offerings valued at
$500,000 or less in a single year to be
sold to 35 or fewer investors subject
only to the requirement that each
investor have a substantive preexisting
relationship with the company despite
the similarity of these provisions to
some restrictions currently imposed on
unregistered security offerings HR 2201
omits several critical investor
protections that are characteristic of
existing exemptions in particular
micro-cap offerings would be exempt from
important regulatory protections set out
in the 1933 Securities Act including
registration disclosure and fraud
protections oversight in the smaller
offering space such as the one proposed
in HR 2201 is important because the SEC
has found fraud in the Michael Copps
micro-cap stock markets is of increasing
concern to regulators as such markets
have proven to be fertile grounds for
fraud and abuse without core protections
HR 2201 would leave investors vulnerable
to an array of investment scams and
abuses with unsophisticated investors
particularly at risk for example the
bill has no restriction on resale in the
past failure to restrict the resale of
unregistered securities has exposed
secondary secondary investors to
fraudulent pump and dump schemes as a
gentlelady from California mentioned
additionally groups like the Americans
for financial reform Center for American
Progress and Public Citizen oppose HR 22
on because it would enable a type of
investment scam known as affinity fraud
in these schemes scammers prey upon
members of identifiable groups such as
ethnic or religious communities or the
elderly often by enlisting respected
community or religious members to help
convince victims that a dubious
investment is legitimate the
proliferation of affinity fraud and low
income communities demonstrates that HR
2201 s pre-existing relationship
requirement would not prevent provide
safeguards against such abuse given
existing exemptions for smaller
companies which provide ample
opportunity for companies to raise
capital while also protect investors HR
2201 is at best unnecessary this bill
would simply create a loophole that
undermines protections against the kinds
of financial abuses and recklessness
that we have already seen damaged our
financial system and hurt people so I
urge my colleagues to oppose HR 2201 I
thank the gentlelady again for yielding
and yield back
gentleman yields back gentlelady from
California reserves her time gentleman
from Texas mr. I yield myself 30 seconds
just to say as I listen to the gentleman
from Rhode Island and the ranking member
their comments are very interesting but
everything they described is already
illegal and their remarks acknowledged
that the SEC can and does bring actions
to enforce the securities laws and shut
down fraud when they discover the fraud
nothing in 2201 eliminates the do Jay's
ability to pursue criminal prosecutions
or fraud nothing in it impacts the SCC's
ability to pursue civil actions against
issuers who engage in fraud under
Section 17 a the Securities Act of 1933
it's just a red herring it's one of the
reasons we
had such poor economic growth under the
Democratic regime now Mr Speaker I am
very very pleased to yield three minutes
to the chairman of the financial
institutions and Consumer Credit
subcommittee of our committee the
gentleman from Missouri mr. Luetkemeyer
job is recognized Thank You mr. chairman
and thank you chairman hunt sling for
your leadership in this issue I also
want to thank the Jim from Minnesota mr.
Emmer for taking a lead on this
important legislation as elected
official have the opportunity to
interact with individuals across my
district who strive to create new or
expand existing small businesses these
are folks that work hard excuse me to
provide for their families and serve as
the backbones of their communities
unfortunately for many entrepreneurs
over-regulation is stiffle there are
ability to innovate and grow the
National Federation of Independent
businesses published a recent study
showing it 30% of small business
respondents cited taxes regulations and
red tape as their most significant
business problem while certain sectors
are reaping the benefits of a strong
economy the reality is the startups and
small businesses are sitting on the
sidelines with limited access to credit
it's something I hear about from
business men and women every single day
be they bankers retailers farmers
doctors in every profession in between
we also know that many startups and
small businesses have historically
turned to local financial institutions
for initial financing in the years after
passage of dodd-frank small bank lending
is down dramatically leaving many
commercial customers scrambling to find
other forms of reasonably priced
financing across the board we're able in
a burdensome system that penalized as
entrepreneurship we need to reverse grow
this course if we want to see a
resurgence of small business creation
and growth HR 2201 is common-sense
legislation that seeks to reverse one
impediment to entrepreneurship mr. Emmer
spill offers a thoughtful approach to a
problem that has hindered and in some
cases prevented all small offerings
across the nation you will appropriately
scale federal rules and regulations
regulatory compliance and will allow
small businesses to access the capital
necessary for growth more specifically
this legislation would exempt certain
non-public micro offerings from the SEC
requirements the bill features
guardrails that allow our
investor protection and subjects any and
all exempted micro offerings to the full
suite of federal and state anti-fraud
laws there's that will be a less
burdensome regulation that sniffles
innovation and increases access to
capital for startups of small businesses
that comply with the parameters included
in the bill this bill is about Main
Street about the small business men and
women in each of our districts I want
again thank and applaud the gentleman
from the SOTA for his hard work on this
legislation asked my colleagues to join
me voting in favor of the legislation
and with that Mr Speaker I yield back
the balance of my time
gentleman yields back his time gentleman
from Texas reserves his time
receive a message the chair will receive
a message mr. speaker a message from the
Senate
Mr Speaker I have been directed by the
Senate to inform the house that the
Senate has passed HR 194 an act to
ensure the effective processing of mail
by federal agencies or for other
purposes Thank You gentlewoman from
California how much time I have left
lady has 18 and a half minutes gentleman
from Texas has 16 minutes general Thank
You mr. speaker and members we have laid
out this pointing exactly how vulnerable
groups and individuals can be taken
advantage of with legislation like this
I don't know exactly where this
legislation originated but I can almost
guarantee you that we are creating
opportunities for individuals who don't
have the best interest of our
constituents at heart to literally get
small groups together 35 I guess are
less and sell them on ideas where they
are raising funds that probably will not
result in profits
as expected by those who are investing
in these schemes no there are no
protections there's no notice the SEC
will not know when and where the schemes
are arising and so I would say to my
colleagues on the opposite side of the
aisle when are we going to act as if we
have the best interests of our
constituents at heart when are we going
to be about protecting consumers rather
than opening up opportunities for them
to be the victims of fraud
we have fraudulent schemes that are
directed at the most vulnerable people I
know where those people who are
organizing these schemes will go they'll
go to our churches where well-meaning
ministers and parishioners will be taken
advantage of in these vulnerable
communities that are always taken
advantage of being taken advantage of we
have people who are the victims of
payday loans where they're paying 400%
for monies that they are born when they
are desperate in between paychecks
we have rent-to-own schemes we have all
kinds of schemes where you know these
convenience stores and places where we
have food deserts are charging extremely
high prices for food that is basically
being sold for regular ordinary good
prices in other communities in some
communities and even in California the
gas taxes are rising we have the rental
market that's going off the scale all
over this country with people not being
able to afford a decent lease or decent
rental space and so here we are just
opening up another opportunity for folks
to be ripped off
and it's going to happen I can guarantee
you that when you have something like
this
that's passed by the Congress of the
United States it's going to be taken
advantage of and the way that this is
constructed it almost begs to be taken
advantage of and so you know what
happens when this kind of thing takes
place and members of Congress put their
their reputations on passing this kind
of legislation when the rip-off start
and people are harmed a few years later
then they're gonna come back with
legislation talking about their
correcting the fraud and the ripoffs
that we caused in the first place when
is this going to stop
we have a Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau that's struggling every day to
protect our consumers and prior to
dodd-frank we had our oversight agencies
with the responsibility of protecting
consumers but they didn't have any real
protection and so dodd-frank reforms
helped to create opportunities for
members of Congress to be able to
protect their consumers and not to be
involved in these kind of schemes but
the opposite side of the aisle has spent
an inordinate amount of time trying to
kill off the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau and they've done it in
so many ways not only do they come up
with amendments time and time again to
try and shut down the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau they treat the
director of the Financial Services
Bureau so badly that they almost deny
him the opportunity to come before our
committee and to be heard so I don't
know whose side legislators are on who
create this kind of crap I don't
understand why it is deemed to be
important to open up the opportunity for
schemes
to not have the SCC with the ability to
know when they're getting started to
have the kind of disclosures to have the
kind of oversight that would protect the
most vulnerable people in our society
well missus speaking members yes this
legislation will probably pass today the
Republicans have the majority votes in
this Congress and I suppose they're
going to get all of their people to vote
for this bill that's going to rip off
some of their constituents and again we
won't be able to stop it because again
they have the majority votes but I want
the people of this country to know and
understand what is happening and who's
doing it to them and why they're having
a difficult time at a time when the
rental market is going off the scale and
they can't afford to pay the first than
the last month's rent to get into a
place I want them to know who's creating
the difficulties in their lives when
their jobs have not increased their pay
and they're still trying to have a
decent quality of life for their
families despite the fact that the pay
does not match the job that they're
doing and they haven't had the pay
increases when are we going to show that
we stand up for the least of these and
when your churches get ripped off and
we're working on some of those schemes
now where even with the responsibilities
that the sec have we have people who are
getting ripped off and here we come with
another piece of legislation and then
what we do is we shade it in terms of
this is for small business development
and then we hear from the opposite side
about all of the companies who started
as little bitty companies in their
garage where they all started without
this bill they didn't need this bill to
start so why are you doing this yeah
you're right there are a lot of
companies and you have named him
particularly in the high-tech industries
that started
and they had some of their own money to
get started with and maybe the family
helped them I don't know but they didn't
have this legislation they didn't need
this legislation nobody needs this
legislation this legislation is harmful
and I would ask my colleagues to vote
against the bill and if there are any
members on the opposite side of the
aisle who really are concerned about
their constituents I would ask them to
defy their leadership at vote against
this bill I reserve the balance of my
time
gentlelady reserves the balance of her
time gentleman from Texas mr. speaker
number one I was very pleased to hear
one of the most compelling indictments
of eight years of the Obama
administration I've ever heard on the
House floor I think the ranking member
for it otherwise I am pleased to yield
three minutes to the vice chairman of
the Financial Institutions and Consumer
Credit subcommittee the gentleman from
Pennsylvania mr. Roth this gentleman is
recognized thank the Chairman field and
I thank the speaker jobs jobs jobs that
is why Mr Speaker I rise today to
express my support for the micro
offering safe harbor Act whose side am I
on the tens of millions of folks who
don't have jobs out there who want job
opportunities we know from some studies
that over the last eight years of wrong
regulation that 650,000 small businesses
have not been created that means six and
a half million jobs six and a half
million people who are not paying
Medicare tax six and a half million
people not paying Social Security tax we
need these people in the game mr.
speaker in this act can help them get
into the game this is an important piece
of Pro jobs legislation and I thank my
colleague mr. Emmer for introducing it
we all want our economy become vibrant
once again so it can generate
opportunity and prosperity for all
Americans unfortunately regulatory
burdens both new and pre-existing often
get in the way of raising capital and
building a business
at hearing after hearing at the
financial services committee we have
heard from financial institutions that
are unable to lend small businesses are
afraid to do so we also have heard from
businesses that cannot find the capital
they need to expand or to retool all of
this has an impact on jobs and wages as
well as on our overall economy the micro
offering safe harbor act is a targeted
common-sense bill that will make it
easier for small businesses to access a
capital that they need to grow
specifically HR 2201 will permit
businesses to issue a limited number of
securities to individuals whom
principals have a pre-existing
relationship this is to conclude family
and friends or often investors in
startups
businesses will only be able to insure a
small amount of securities five hundred
thousand a year but that's a step in the
right direction towards helping
businesses that need funding this is
good policy that will make it easier for
small businesses to get off the ground
and grow and add jobs at the same time
this bill ensures that our regular our
regulators can continue to police fraud
and abuse and to do so aggressively on
that point there is no ambiguity fraud
is illegal and it will not be tolerated
or excused again I strongly support the
micro offering safe harbor Act it is
good for the economy and good for
hardworking Americans it's good for jobs
jobs jobs I urge my colleagues to
support this legislation and I yield
back
gentleman yields back gentleman from
Texas reserves his time gentlelady from
California thank you very much mr.
speaker by allowing entities to sale
unregistered securities based solely on
a pre-existing relationship with the
investor HR 2201 would create a roadmap
for affinity fraud affinity fraud is a
type of investment scam where swindlers
prey upon members of identifiable groups
such as ethnic or religious communities
are the elderly often affinity frosters
take advantage of pre-existing
relationships to endanger trust and
convince vut
victims that a dubious investment is
legitimate the Securities and Exchange
Commission has found that such fraud
posed heightened risk to investors
because they can be difficult for
regulators or law enforcement officials
to detect particularly where the
fraudsters have used respected community
or religious leaders to convince others
to join the investment the following
cases represent a sampling of recent
affinity fraud actions from around the
United States in August 2013 the SEC
halted an offering fraud scheme where
Steven Bruce Heights a Utah residents
purporting to be an investment adviser
so phony investment contracts to more
than fifteen of his former clients
family members and friends according to
the SE C's complaint Heinz raised four
million in investor funds which he used
to engage in high-risk trading of
futures contracts and to pay his own
personal expenses such as family
vacations to Mexico and a six hundred
thousand dollar loan among the investors
taken in behind scam was quote the
recent widow of a church associate of
heights
who invested with Heinz after he
volunteered to assist her with her
finances and investments after her
spouse died quote-unquote in 2012 the
SEC stopped a 7.5 million fraud
operation targeting the Persian Jewish
community in Los Angeles the SCC's
assistant Regional Director stated that
sure then Niemann quote deceived members
of his own community to raise money in a
fraudulent Ponzi scheme by exploiting
investors trust in him Neiman was
continually able to raise more money to
pay back existing investors and financed
an extravagant lifestyle quote-unquote
according to this SCC's complaint quote
among other things Neiman used investor
funds to pay for his wedding and
honeymoon
his wife's engagement ring luxury cars
and VIP tickets to entertainment venue
quote unquote in 2015 the SCC
permanently barred John Allen Russell
from the securities industry after
Russell pled guilty to securities fraud
in Colorado State Court the SCC's
administrative law judge found that
Russell obtained almost $300,000 by
selling debt securities to an elderly
victim who suffered from dementia and
Alzheimer's disease
the ALJ also determined that quote
Russell scheme may have involved a
penalty fraud because the misconduct
began a few years after the victim acted
as Russell's Godfather at his baptismal
these cases demonstrate that HR 2201 s
pre-existing relationship requirements
would not provide any meaningful
determined against abuse on the contrary
it would encourage opportunistic conduct
targeting communities I would urge my
colleagues to join me in voting no for
this bill given all that the SEC is able
to do they can't keep up with these
schemes and now you're gonna open up the
door but then to have to wrestle or
we're trying to help people who are
victims of these kind of schemes I
reserve the balance of my time
you reserves the balance of her time
gentleman from Texas